hi I'm Gary Kasparov and I'm here to
answer your chess related questions from
Twitter
why do all question mark chess players
point at pieces squares with middle
finger do we I'm not sure I I never paid
attention to that fact maybe we have to
ask a psychologist to see the enough
samples for us to come up with such an
such a definite conclusion bishop or
Knight it depends if you're religious or
not the general assumption is that those
slight pieces are of equal price in
pounds I think Bobby Fischer was the
first one who indicated that Bishop
should be valued higher 3.25 three
points for night I was more reserved
actually I put 3.15 four for Bishop but
now with looking at some of the computer
games I would say that maybe Fischer's
evaluation was was correct after
machines played millions of games we
just learned that bishops value is
simply higher since in many more cases
it was more useful piece do I have to
develop all of my minor pieces before
activating my queen the answer is yes
queen is the strongest piece but you can
argue the weakest one because if it's
attacked it has to move move move away
because it's most valuable piece I can
come up with many opening positions were
activating the queen is it's very
natural so there are many openings where
your queen is being developed at as
early as boom four or five I would
recommend for weak players to follow the
rule and not to bring your queen into
the battle too early but for those who
are making progress in the game of chess
by studying openings professionally you
have to be cautious all the time trying
to apply general rules are universally
all the time why do chess players tend
to castle
even though it's villa restricts the
kings
King safety is a number-one priority and
obviously after castle you remove king
from the vulnerable position in the
center so restricting the Kings movement
is is not as as dangerous as living the
king in the open you are in doubt and
you want to castle but short or long in
one and two it depends on your on your
mood I would say if you Castle short
it's a roughly even game but you cannot
expect to gain an advantage so castling
long is more aggressive more ambitious
but it's it's riskier now with the
second one but has very comfortable game
they can simply Castle a short and have
excellent position I would probably go
short castle but maybe it's my age
talking what is your favorite gambit
opening in chess with a white B black I
don't think gambits are just offering
you an advantage against the world
prepared to open opponent
I loved Evans gambit I played there
quite a few games and some of them are
instructive wins now was black we played
a couple of times
ball gambit banker gambit known in the
free world I can only think of any real
gambit Swiss was black except this dated
the banker gambit where you can that you
can employ ID ID at the professional
level is the casbah in your expert
opinion
why doesn't Adam Carlson for that matter
ever use something wild like Kings
gambit because it's wild players that
level they they don't play wild openings
and serious games I can tell you spend a
lot of time analyzing it and it always
ends up with whose negative results so
that's why if you're a big fan of the
King's gambit
I wouldn't recommend you holding your
breath expecting Carlsen or other top
players employing it in the top
tournaments oh another note do you
advocate Evans gambit or stronger player
or will it be crush these days it's hard
to say no for Evans gambit because I
want quite a few games very memorable
one against vision
in 1995 the first time I used Evans
gambit
so for strong player someone who's known
for his or her preparation I think you
have to be very cautious by making such
a choice it depends very much on what
you mean it's a strong player so because
we can we can disagree on the definition
though I think that if you want to play
such a sharp opening as Evans gambit
sacrificing opponent before you are not
thinking what equalizing you thinking
about taking Isha t'v and crushing your
opponents so I'm again it's up to you
but just bear in mind that Evans gambit
has disappeared completely from from the
games of the top players can anyone
recommend a good book on chest end game
mark vronsky's book end game it helps
strong players to become stronger so I
enjoyed reading the book and as it's you
can always learn something from there
even if you if you are weak relevant
weak player or a very strong one is
control of the center one of the most
important things you must do in order to
win the game of chess yeah it is very
very important but I can give you many
examples where you control the center
but the king is being mated I would
strongly recommend that you put King
safety as a number-one priority tech AI
types as a genuine question how much
should we read into the ability of a
computer to quickly get really good at
chess or go it's impressive but it's
also about logic and involves very
constrained and ultimately limited
choices I think you answer the question
it's about the logic but it's a closed
system because we establish the rules we
should recognize that the moment the
open-ended system has been limited to
closed framework machines will do a
better job by simply just going around
this and establishing their own set of
priorities chess and other games they
like all they offer income and excellent
actual opportunity to to study the
ability of machines for us to look into
much bigger problems of the universe and
nature learning chess
why does the horsey one move so crazy
why not straight lines like castle hat I
can tell you that in any version of
chess there are different rules and
different patterns for instance Japanese
game called shogi it has many different
rules that are there an issue for our
eyes because we train just to look at
our chess I think it's just it's somehow
it's a combination of of the different
abilities of the pieces and I can tell
you that our forebears did a great job
by actually coming up with such a
balanced game thank you very much for
asking all these questions they were
very different some of them are too
professional to my taste some of them
are very primitive again to my taste but
that's the beauty of the game of chess
you could enjoy the game you can ask
questions even if you are very weak
player or if you are experienced club
player only with a very very strong
player and that's creates this global
chess family and I'm always happy to
address any concern that comes from
every layer of our chests knowledge
in the world